[Music]
Pete lands
perhaps Canada's most precious resource
and yet one few people get to see and
even fewer appreciate
for this waterlogged landscape is
humankind's best ally in the fight
against climate change
[Music]
unless we disturb it
deep in the Hudson Bay lowlands
scientists are trying to unravel the
mysteries of what lies far below the
surface
[Music]
this peat soil is likely 2 000 years old
it's been storing carbon
so the darker the soil is or the pitas
here the more carbon it tends to have
this ancient ecosystem absorbs carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere and traps it
deep in the soil below
it's the world's second largest intact
peat land storing an estimated 35
billion tons of carbon but it's at risk
of losing that status and becoming a
massive new source of greenhouse gases
[Music]
we traveled to Ontario's far north to
see the peatlands first hand alongside
researchers for McMaster University and
World Wildlife Fund Canada
it's an isolated part of the country
accessible in the summertime only by
plane
it's a tapestry of peatlands woven
together by streams channels that all
flow into some of the last undammed
rivers in North America it is a really
beautiful place
the vast Wetlands stretch from Manitoba
across Northern Ontario and into Quebec
we're on route to the small Creek
community of pewanik
Michelle calamidine is part of a
research Collective that's mapping the
carbon density across the Hudson Bay
lowlands
there's still a lot of gaps in our
knowledge of the peaklands especially
when it comes to carbon and so we're
here to try and fill some of that data
Gap
do you guys have a walkie with you
locals are joining the scientists and
helping them take peat cores which will
determine the areas that store the most
carbon
the first sampling site once we get
there we have
[Music]
it's a treacherous hike there are no
formal trails in this area but our local
guides lead the way
[Music]
when the ground below our feet starts to
feel like we're walking on a sponge we
know we're getting close to the
peatlands
[Music]
one two three
so the total card length we have is 50
centimeters and it's all Pete with Woody
debris through it David Hunter grew up
here in pewanik he's joining the team as
a sampling technician
it's exciting to be doing this work here
in pewanick at my home Community this
project gives me an opportunity to
Traverse the land in a new way with new
intent I'm looking at the land with A
New Perspective
[Music]
so this is sphagnum moss as the mosque
grows it pushes down layers of
vegetation over time the dead plants
gradually build up and form peat it's an
incredibly slow process it takes 1 000
years to form one meter of peat
plant matter is building up informing
this peatland it ends up storing a
massive amount of carbon and that's the
power of peatlands Lorna Harris has
studied these remarkable Wetlands for 17
years and now with Wildlife Conservation
Society Canada she's working to protect
them
not many Canadians are aware that they
have one of the world's largest
peatlands in Canada it is essentially
our equivalent to the Amazon rainforest
in fact Canada's Northern peatlands
store five times the amount of carbon
per square meter than the Amazon
rainforest
but they do more than just sequester
carbon and cool the planet
s act as a natural water filter
improving the quality of fresh water
that feeds into the vast network of
streams rivers and lakes
historically peatlands have never been
seen as a good place they are always
seen as desolate wastelands full of bugs
wet you can't access them
nothing of value in them
but for the almost gego people this land
is home
[Music]
what you should take Thousand Years two
thousand years to change it's happening
in decades now because everything is
melting so fast you can see it Sam
Hunter monitors changes in the
environment around pewanik
from the water quality of the rivers to
the flight path of migratory Birds many
species of birds have disappeared the
waterfowl the geese since my childhood
they have changed their behavior because
of the disappearing ponds
and a lot of them are moving to the high
Arctic
due to the high cost of food up north
seasonal harvesting is not only
culturally significant but necessary
it's a two and a half hour trip by boat
to the edge of Hudson Bay where many
community members have their hunting
camps
the coastline is a vibrant meeting place
for Caribou migratory Birds and the
Region's most famous resident the polar
bear
the Bay's tidal Flats give way to grassy
salt marshes
and peatlands dotted with small ponds
and creeks
all of those peatlands are connected to
the streams to the rivers that all flew
into Hudson Bay
[Music]
this is where Marcel metat has placed
his Gill Nets since he was a kid he
comes here almost every weekend to hunt
and fish along the shores of Hudson Bay
when a Ty comes in it's gonna be like
maybe like 10 feet high
today only a few fish are caught in his
Nets on a good day he'll catch 50
Whitefish here which he then hands out
to families back in pijuana
[Music]
I'm gonna make a smoked fish the way I I
thought by my parents
cut it in the center on the way
it's natural like the way we do a long
time ago like it's more healthier than
we are
it's a tradition passed down from
generation to generation much like the
peat lands the knowledge indigenous
people have of the land has accumulated
over thousands of years
in our language the people call it
mistake it's the muskeg you know the the
wetlands it's the breathing lands of
Mother Earth Vern chichu is the director
of lands and resources for the Michigan
Council which represents seven Cree
first nations in the region
by combining indigenous knowledge with
modern science he hopes first nations in
the region can gain a deeper
understanding of the muskeg and the
changes they're seeing due to climate
change
there's sinkholes that are developing
there's huge areas of land that sunk
because of permafrost melting
Northern regions of Canada are warming
faster than the rest of the country
these changes in the landscape are
making it more challenging and
potentially dangerous to travel across
the land
warms up it rains and it's impacting on
the Winter Road system
these days the winter Ice Road is only
safe for about two weeks of the year a
very short window to bring up essential
Goods
but climate change is far from the only
threat facing these small remote
communities
a major mining development has been
proposed in their backyard bringing with
it the promise of jobs roads and
prosperity but it could also mean
irreversible damage to the peatlands
hello hey how's it going Ana Baggio
shows us rare images of what mining
exploration looks like in Northern
Ontario it may kind of surprise people
to see what the level activity is this
is 2010 but I'll show you some other
photos too just to kind of give you a
sense
clear cutting and exploratory drilling
this all happens long before a mine goes
through any environmental review or
approval because of the contrast in the
winter you can really see they had a
drill rig and then they drag the drill
rigs through and then those are all the
platforms from where they did the
drilling
Anna is the conservation director for
wildlands League they're a
not-for-profit group that has been
tracking developments in the region for
the past 13 years
how have you seen the mining exploration
activity change from 2010 to 2022. the
camp looks a little bigger to me
but the bigger change to me is just how
sprawling the activities are emanating
from the camps outwards all these lines
you see this is all coming out to
facilitate exploration
the rush happened in the early part of
the decade and now we you know we're
concerned it's happening again
mineral deposits discovered in 2007 led
to political rhetoric proclaiming
Northern Ontario as Canada's next oil
sands
in the years since dozens of mining
companies have made the track 500
kilometers north of Thunder Bay in
search of chromite nickel copper and
Cobalt
the area has been dubbed the Ring of
Fire
so The Story Goes that the exploration
folks that were there in the beginning
were Johnny Cash Fest and they saw that
there's a bit of a crescent shape when
you look at the deposits and they they
called it the Ring of Fire
a looming shortage of minerals needed
for electric vehicle batteries and other
Green Tech has renewed interest in these
deposits
Ontario Premier Doug Ford has made
opening the region to mining a priority
with the support of the First Nations
Community we're going to both hop on
that bulldozer and build that road as
sure as I'm standing here
but so far the ring of fire has not
lived up to the hype
early claims that there were 60 billion
dollars worth of minerals underground
have been debunked
end of the Dozen first nations in the
region only two formally support the
project but that hasn't stopped mining
companies or the province from foraging
ahead as of last year there were 26 000
mining claims covering approximately 5
000 square kilometers
all of the the minerals that the mining
companies want to extract are underneath
the peatlands deep in the Bedrock so to
access those locations they have to
remove the peatland from the surface
when peatlands are drained or damaged
the carbon they've sequestered for
thousands of years gets released back
into the atmosphere in the form of
greenhouse gases
that carbon is irrecoverable so that
means that once it's lost to the
atmosphere we just cannot get it back
within our lifetimes just degrading 10
percent of the peatlands in the Hudson
Bay lowland will have a significant
Global impact on climate
we cannot reach our climate targets we
cannot reach Net Zero if we open up this
region
the ring of fire remains largely
inaccessible
the three roads needed to get there have
not yet been approved or fully funded
and the estimated cost of building the
roads has jumped to two billion dollars
all on the taxpayers tab
Ontario mines Minister George Perry is
the man tasked with bringing the roads
and future mining projects to fruition
so this project was once valued at 60
billion dollars do you have the current
valuation no I don't have a would you
say a current valuation but anecdotally
people are you know and and the mining
people are saying this is a trillion
dollar Project based on the increase the
value of critical minerals that are
already established being in the ground
it's not a formal valuation it's mining
people that anecdotally will will uh
will say this is a trillion dollar
project so we contacted wailu Metals an
Australian mining company with the
largest deposit Holdings in the region
we as CEO Luca jackovacsi if he agrees
with that trillion dollar figure I don't
mean to laugh but there is a lot of myth
around the ring of fire that number a
number like that is
um is way exaggerated the ring of fire
is a special area but numbers like that
are a little bit silly Luca wouldn't
speculate on the value of the minerals
in today's market
he says the company is still in the
early stages of figuring that out how
can you assure Canadians that this is a
good use of taxpayer money when we don't
know the firm numbers of what's
underground this isn't all about just
building the mines
the billion dollars that the the
province has announced is all about
developing new communities you and the
premier have both spoken about the
services that this would bring to these
remote First Nations what plans does the
province have to build a hospital up
north or high schools there are
hospitals that are being built right now
in mussini but that's pretty far east
like think about Westward web equation
Falls those communities that are going
to get that road access they're getting
well served with the clinics that are in
in those communities right now
for decades decades to help bring down
the cost of living
but New Roads bring new concerns
what about people from the South coming
up to hunt or take from the land
you know who's going to control those
you know
often it's not just a mining Road it
then becomes Hunters Fishers more
exploration activity it would be
unchecked unrestrained if we don't put
rules in place they all get built
by law indigenous communities must be
consulted by The Province but they have
no veto power
Pia wanick in the muskegawa communities
further away are worried about the
downstream impacts mining could have
we're not only Downstream we are down
musking we're talking about an area
that's mostly water and so if you're
going to mine in a region like that you
don't know what's going to happen right
to anticipate the future impact
development could have the federal
government is conducting a regional
assessment
we asked Canada's environment Minister
Stephen gubo if his government supports
the ring of fire project
in my days as an environmentalist
the result of federal impact assessment
was always the same it was always yes
and now we're saying well sometimes it's
going to be known there are places where
we won't go
because they're too ecologically
sensitive because they're for for
indigenous peoples culturally or
spiritually very very important to think
we can meet Canada's climate targets if
we develop the Hudson Bay lowland pea
lands well if we do it in a manner that
is environmentally sounding yes will the
mining projects have impacts of course I
mean we have to be frank and upfront
about it will they have more impacts
than if we continue burning fossil fuels
uh that that's that that's the question
we we have to wrestle with but it will
be that some projects we come to the
conclusion that they have too much
impacts and they simply won't go ahead
while gebo says the region is critically
important he would not commit to
protecting the peat lands
and so the fate of this ecosystem
remains mired in this complex Balancing
Act
came to ring of fire in the second
largest carbon sink in the world coexist
[Music]
so we do have to be very careful about
any decisions we make about what happens
in this region
anything we do here is going to impact
the global climate
[Music]